[Music]
welcome to part two of the fundamentals
of kicking series this part is going to
be focused in on pivoting of the foot
and how that relates to correctly
turning your hips into position to
execute certain kicks
[Music]
now each part in this series is designed
to be like a piece of a jigsaw puzzle
that fit together and integrating them
all together at the same time will
improve your kicks exponentially now on
the surface each part of this series
might seem almost too simplistic or kind
of just common sense and you might be
thinking now this is just the series for
like beginners or people who've never
experienced kicking before but that's
seriously not the case in fact if you've
actually been training for a while
you're more likely to have some bad
habits ingrained which are hampering
your progress without you really known
about it so try to keep an open mind
with this and try to identify where you
might be doing some of these things
within your own technique and you'll be
able to improve yourself common sense
does not mean common practice so bear
that in mind
pivoting and turning the hips is
probably the single most common problem
I see martial artists face and a lot of
people become frustrated because they
just can't get their body to do what
they wanted to do I believe the major
reason that people don't really know
about this is that were never actually
taught it by the instructors and that's
likely because they didn't even really
understand it themselves if my own
Taekwondo instructor would just say the
differences between kicks and say this
is a front kick this is a side kick and
that's about as far as it went with no
more detailed explanation I only learnt
this stuff by watching my own footage
back and then comparing it to other
people I wanted to move like and then
adjusting it from there when many people
identify there's a problem with their
kicking they'll set out to change
something thinking that's the underlying
cause but often that's not the case with
regards to this part of kicking 99% of
people will point to what they think is
a lack of flexibility being the cause of
why they're not able to move in the way
they want to but overwhelmingly a bad
pivot which leads to the hips not being
able to open correctly is actually the
cause which just leads to a lackluster
kick at the end this would be like
having a problem with a movie that
you're watching at the cinema and your
solution is to yell at the screen in
front of you hoping it will change the
result of that is completely frivolous
because the real origin is coming from
the projector room and by the time it
hits the screen it's already a done deal
so now let's talk about the two most
predominant positions of the hips when
kicking and these are Square and turned
so the square position is applicable to
things like front kicks and axe kicks
and the turning position is applicable
to the others like side kick or kick and
turning kick the square position means
that our hips face directly towards the
target
turn position is where we face side on
to our target which is achieved through
pivoting on the standing foot correctly
pivoting on the standing foot is a
paramount importance to getting your
hips turned into the correct position to
execute an effective kick this is
something that I believe is grossly
misunderstood by many martial artists
and as a consequence overlooked meaning
that their kicks never really improve as
mentioned before many people believe a
lack of flexibility is the reason behind
their poor kicking technique but
overwhelmingly it is because of bad
pivoting and if you continue to do that
not only will you ingrain it into your
muscle memory and the kicks won't be
anywhere near as effective as they could
be you can also grind the joints of the
legs together and risk injury as well
the best way to illustrate this point is
by talking about the angle at which a
kick comes in toward its target so if
this is your centerline here and say if
you're doing a turning kick that comes
in from the side like this now if you
are kicking correctly however you kick
and whatever height you kick out the
kick should come in at the same angle
each time the hallmark of a poor pivot
and bad alignment of the hips is where
the kick starts low okay and then as it
goes up the angle starts to go upwards
until they're almost performing a full
kick when it's actually supposed to be a
turning kick so as you can see here this
is starting off okay but as the angle
goes up the kick gets weaker and this is
a really weak kicking angle here as
opposed to turning the hips correctly
look at the alignment of the body it's
completely different and even at the
highest point of the kick it's still a
nice strong kick so the way we want to
pivot for the turning of the hips
correctly is by fully turning the foot
away from your target so that the heel
is facing towards it you don't
necessarily need to do that to get the
right hip position at a low angle for
instance but it's a good habit to get
into doing whatever height you kick out
so that you'll naturally do it when
kicking higher and this is the way I do
it
the key to really dynamic kicking
technique is to get into that pivoted
position as fast as you can
the faster you're able to get into that
position with your hips aligned then the
more explosive your kick is going to be
with kicking all of the energy starts
with our feet as we pivot then travels
up the body to its apex where the kick
is extended you might want to imagine
this in terms of the metaphor of when
you like whip a towel out the stored
energy is transferred from your hand
through the towel to the end point where
it's finally discharged so by remaining
very relaxed to start with you're going
to use them the muscles of your legs
combine with your hands to turn your
body into that correctly pivoted
position that'll make the kick can have
just happen all by itself after that and
one of the best ways I've found to
actually do this when you get
comfortable with it is to almost jump
yourself into that position so the foot
goes from exactly where you're facing
your target in your fighting stance to
completely turned into the correct
pivoting position which makes the kick
really really powerful and explosive you
see many people kick like this where
they slowly turn the hip into the pivot
which is a good starting point but once
you're familiar with it then you should
begin to speed it all up in a moment I'm
going to close out this video with a
collection of different clips of
different clicking techniques with the
pivot clearly shown to illustrate my
point and perhaps the best way against
practice this is slowly holding on to
something for your balance so that you
can really really focus on that element
that we want to burn into your muscle
memory in this case the pivot and
turning the hips correctly that way you
can really concentrate on that pivot and
practice how it will feel to kick in
this new way while also strengthening
specific muscles that you're going to
need to be able to keep the form at
higher intensity levels I hope you
enjoyed this video guys and I will see
you next time
[Music]
you